you
[Music]
so it's my my pleasure to introduce
Moshe Havarti today from Rice University
I've known Moshe since um before he was
established as a researcher actually his
PhD advisor was my first major
collaborator as a researcher at the time
he was at Hebrew University and he said
you know I got this really great student
and you know you you ought to keep an
eye on and this guy is really going to
be good I swear that his accomplishments
and awards read like a list of a large
fraction of the awards that are open to
any computer scientist that he's has
three IBM outstanding Innovation Awards
the cig act girdle prize the ACM connell
aqus award the ACM sigmod innovations
award Blaise Pascal medal that I loaded
a National Academy of Engineering
National Academy of Science American
Academy of Arts and Letters it's so on
the the he he also has done a huge
service to the computer science
community by taking ACM see ACM which
was a really much ignored journal that
that and and really recast it
resurrected it really conceptualized it
as in a way at a vision for how it could
actually be relevant and widely read and
he actually made it happen and served in
addition to everything else he does
being a famous researcher in several
different fields and writing hundreds of
papers somehow he managed to carve out
time in for ten years to to lead that
effort as editor-in-chief so I think we
all grow Emma Greta debt a debt of
gratitude for having done that as well
but today he's on a new mission on the
affect that we have in in automating
all kinds of work and just you know what
what is that effect first if we're gonna
if if we want to have enough we want to
improve the lot of people whose jobs are
eliminated I think the first thing to do
is to understand exactly what's going on
and he's going to be telling us about
that today
so no chef thank you thank you for the
opportunity today to address you on this
topic which is I think of the highest
importance and just to give you some
idea where I'm coming at it so it's
probably fair to say for but still to
you the filthiest for my 30 years of my
career that was my main focus publish
papers get them cited get a good H
number yada yada yada but about five
years ago but five six years ago I start
making and I'll explain a bit later how
come into it thinking about the the
societal consequence of the technology
that we all working so hard to develop
and I'm find myself about two years ago
in a press conference and a reporter
from The Guardian asked which jobs will
not be automated and I said would the
general convey at the conventional
wisdom is the jobs require a lot of a
human interaction and emotional
intelligence that these jobs would not
be automated and then on the spur of the
moment I said but I'm not so sure would
you bet against sex robots and of course
this was a soundbite and you see the
Guardian run with this with this
headline and and a thousand newspaper
quoted this me on this one
so much so that some of my friends now
call me sex robots motion
so let's let's kind of recap the AI
story first of all in a very briefly so
just to remind ourselves you know you
cannot exactly trace exactly where it
started you can find some people say
it's not really in the 19th century you
can go back and find people thinking
about this but maybe it's it's not an
arbitrary point to identify it with alan
joy who in 1950 wrote a very well cited
paper so we are mostly thinking about
Alan Turing and Turing machines but the
paper that he published in 1950
Computing Machinery and intelligence
publishing a philosophy journal mind I
believe is his most cited paper and
again the paper is very famous for the
imitation game the Turing test but
that's actually my opinion the weakest
part of the paper the the main part of
the paper is a philosophical paper on
the possibility of machine intelligence
and tooling goes through a list of
objection to machine intelligence and he
decisively unused against all of them
and he concludes by saying yes machines
will be thought to be sinking he said by
night by by the end of the century
we will talk as if machines are thinking
well the century has come and gone and I
don't think still ever say well you know
my laptop is thinking about what's the
next slide to show I don't think that's
how we talked about and indeed our
optimism was a common feature in the day
I in the AI feel you go back címon
renewal 1958
well chest 10 years max we will solve
chess AI will take us maybe 30 years
said Minsky 1967 so because of this
early optimism there were periods we can
own as AI winters where the field have
almost fallen into disrepute when I was
a PhD student AI was a suspicious field
you know people who over promise and
under deliver kind of a you can always
come up with some names are associated
with this error and to me to me the
turning point on a personal level in
1997 so I was already a left IBM I was
already attached to university I have
good still very good connection with IBM
IBM invited me to
come and watch the game between Kasparov
and deep blue they paid my fly to pay
for the hotel I couldn't say no so I go
there and I watch the first game in the
first game
Kasparov was black was white which is
perceived to have an advantage and
Kasparov won the first game
now remember then thinking okay I
believe that one day computer will win
but probably the time has not come and
we are still fairly new in new stone we
didn't have many friends I left my wife
behind I said okay I'm going to cut a
visit short and I'm going to go back
home and I missed the second game the
second game the blue was white Kasparov
had to play more aggressive game and he
laid the trap too deep blue and he blew
not only did not fall into the trap but
came out of it with a sequence of move
that was so brilliant that you see
Kasparov is reaction to that he walks
off you know he he considered the game
he walks off the game and for years he
claimed that it was not really deep blue
there must have been a secretive of gun
master playing against him he just came
up he just last year he published
finally a book to the 20th anniversary
of this when she finally yes it was the
computer has won he considered it but
that was kind of a really turning point
because this poem is said that for years
there were some time the future suddenly
it was the first significant
accomplishment by AI and then in 2011 I
came did it again this time with Watson
and now it was in jeopardy and you know
we all saw that the chess at the end of
day that curve would change the
computational game if you can just look
deeply enough into the game into the
game tree you can you can defeat humans
but jeopardy require a whole different
type of intelligence you know you have
to answer clever questions about Airport
in Chicago that have some to do with
world war 2 and you have to think well
it's Midway Airport I mean it requires
some all kind of knowledge of culture in
history and language skills so that was
the moment that for me I thought wow
it's not just about some remote future
this is actually happening now I think
the next significant accomplishment I
would put what happened last year which
is that now the mantle has moved to IBM
to Google and alphago both listed all in
go now go you can see here go is in some
sense a simple game you have a 19 byte
by 19 board just whiten in black and
white pieces there are many many more
configurations so the game tree is known
to be much much much bigger and the for
go he'll be considered a challenge after
chess people have tried many many years
to do better in go and deterministic
search clear was not going to walk so
alphago used first of all randomized
three cells technique but still that's
not enough so now the use machine
learning and would have done first of
all they digested all published games
and then alphago stopped playing and
guess it gets itself and built a big
deep model of how to make what a good
configuration what are good moves
this is philosophically significance
because it means now that the way
alphago played is by having deep
intuition not having good rules how to
play but having good intuition and to
understand the significance of this you
we have to go back more than 15 years
and find a philosophy Palani Karl
Polanyi who ought in 1966 and this
became known as a polanyi's paradox how
can we ever hope to have AI when there
are many many things that we can do but
we cannot explain how we do that if you
think about how you drive you just drive
you don't have a set of rules that you
follow in the thought was if you don't
have a set of rules that we follow it's
all about intuitive feeling how can we
ever program this in answer is that we
know what is dance right machine
learning we're going to learn from data
and it's interesting that the Palani put
driving as the kind of a a challenge for
AI because it has been a grand challenge
for right now for actually more than a
decade going back in ninety in 2005 the
DARPA Grand Challenge
eventually one by Stanford well it's
transfer team this is Sebastian tool in
more than 130 miles in unrehearsed rail
in Death Valley and two years later CMU
now doing it in urban area and notice
this is more than ten years ago this is
before we had all the chips and all that
we have today and before we had deep
learning already people were making
significant progress in in in automated
driving and of course by now this
picture is I think everyone here
recognizes there's no clock called the
Google car or more formally the way
Macau right and so I think this is an
amazing thing was going to happen I'll
talk more I want to talk about it
because I think this is going to be the
most significant technical development
that I'm going to see in my lifetime in
suspect this is true for many of you
okay unless you're very young and then
maybe you see other things but for most
of us I think this is it and let me put
it in a context why I think this is so
significant he's going to launch another
transportation revolution what's the
first one invasion of the will but 5,000
us BC what has he done to us well we'll
not been able to build the pyramids if
we didn't have wheels right you can't
carry these big boulders on your back
what's the next one after that the
domestication of the horse okay until
there if you want to go somewhere you
have to walk there now you can rider you
don't have to walk on your own feet and
if you think about it you have the
Mongol Empire which is the biggest land
Empire ever all conquered on a whole
spec after the domestication of the
horse which happened more than 5000
years ago
nothing significant happens in land
transportation I mean ignoring seed you
know water transportation until the
steam locomotive the same locomotive you
can say it's the beginning of the enough
industrial revolution in some sense in a
big way and we cannot imagine the United
States is a continental country if we
did not have this
trains going east you know east-west
before that if you want to go from New
York to San Francisco
what was the fastest way of getting from
New York to San Francisco a boat all
around America okay
so the train the train made modem on
during the modern United States and then
in 1908 the Ford Model T the car at this
point is about 50 years old always
started in Europe in the 1850s I think
but this is the first mass-produce mass
consumed car and it gave us this and
this and this the car the automobile I
claim is the most significant industrial
product of the twentieth century
we would like to think it's the computer
no it's not the computer the computer
will probably be the most significant
product with 21st century but if you
bring someone from 50 years ago 1967 and
they go to sleep Rip Van Winkle to wake
up today how does the world look
different well every everybody carries
some something with them and a lot of
zombies are walking around looking at
things but other than that the fabric of
life does not look that different
between 1967 and today some years ago I
went to Cuba and it was like going in in
Time Machine 50 years back and it looks
dated but not dramatically different the
city in 50 years now in the future would
be dramatically different because the
cities of today were shaped by the
automobile they were architect by the
automobile they because the United set
is such a big country the automobile you
of such or such significance it gave
rise to a mighty industry I mean we can
remember the chairman of GM saying 50
years ago what's good for Jim is good
for the country the United States will
not have become a superpower if you
don't have the industrial mind it came
from the automobile industry World War
two was worn by the Inc by the American
industry think of how many movies the
Ottoman will play a role a cultural
symbol of adulthood and freedom in
this is going to change and it will
change for one important reason and this
the cost the human cost of automobile is
incalculable we just learn to accept it
more than a million people every year
are killed by automobile crashes 30,000
in United States alone we just learn to
accept it in fact even the old car
accident is a marketing term because if
you say accident it's a it's an act of
God
you know it's beyond us and the source
of the social cause of it if you
actually go down to think about it how
many people are killed in Maine in
effect mostly people in the middle part
of their life um about teenage to-to-to
early middle age in fact Texas only
finally now passed the law it's now
illegal to text and text and drive-ins
in Texas thank you thank you thank you
thank you
the leading cause of death among young
people today DW driving while texting
used to be I right now it's about it's
texting so this I think this by itself
justify pushing for the automation of
car now this is a book published by by
Ralph Nader in the mid-60s blaming the
automobile industry but the reason that
we have so many car crashes you want to
know why look to your left look to your
right it's all about us okay 95% of of
courses are caused by humans
I do sometimes an interesting experiment
I ask everybody to write down whether
they're above average driver or below
average rider then I ask all the people
who are above average to raise their
hand and it's usually about 80% of the
audience so probably today in Silicon
Valley this is kind of the hot one of
the hottest technical trend you have you
know some estimates over 250 companies
working this area from the from the
mainstream and car manufacturers GM Ford
and the like
some technology company way more Baidu
maybe up and nobody knows the
transportation companies such as uber
and lyft
lots and lots of startups technical
issues there's no agreement
some people say five years to me that
sounds overly optimistic maybe 15 is
more realistic the adoption will be more
difficult I don't think it will take
2025 years for for adoption will be
gradual than many many legal issues that
need to be resolved in many states the
law says a moving vehicle requires to
have a human driver in the car so the
laws will have to change it will be
profound business disruption most car
seats idly and doing nothing and I will
have an opportunity to actually have a
more rational and more effective use of
the of the fleet huge a major loss of
business including for example people
are now worried where will we get organ
for transplantation if we don't have all
these people king bike by car crashes
still I think of it is going to be a
huge benefit to society mostly if we
just can save every year million lives I
cannot see anything more important than
that but then let's look at this picture
this is the oldest say this is 2014 I
don't think it sent automatically it
shows all the 50 states and it shows the
most common job in every state in more
than half the states it's a truck driver
now this doesn't mean that the majority
of the people in the center type driver
this is an artifact of how you aggregate
jobs but still he tell you that lots of
drivers turns out in the United States
they are about 4 million talking taxi
drivers if you bought in the category
you look at people whose job include
driving is a major component of the job
think of like postal workers now I
talked about 15 million people and in
fact if you can automate vehicles you
can automate really the whole supply
chain and if you look for example at
cargo cargo ship well they're much
easier to automate and then Karthik
to deal with kids chasing balls on the
on the street and in fact the parties
are going to launch this year they are
also planning to launch a cargo ship if
you look at port today port today are
almost hundred percent containerized and
it means they can be fully automated I
am sure you have seen the videos of the
Amazon warehouses we have the robots
that move move the things what what
still robots have a hard time hard time
doing is this picking up an object is
still hard but they're working on it so
we can see we can see a new disruption
of the economy and massive lovel jobs
now you talk to economists about it and
it's all yeah technology destroy job
it's create new jobs there's a new quali
was being reached nothing to worry about
that's the standard line that you hear
from economists here is a Ken Rogoff a
neoclassical economist at Harvard I
think and he says all people have been
worried about mass unemployment since on
revolution it never happened it never
will now notice that even he says
something about a long period of painful
adjustment excuse me how long exactly
it doesn't say let's move on don't worry
nothing to worry about other economies
such as a poor Krugman noble Nobel Prize
winner and columnist for New York Times
is a bit more pessimistic he said can
innovation and progress really help
large number of workers maybe even
workers in general it was is that it can
yes maybe how workers will be helped so
there is this debate among the new
Luddites were saying this time it is
different and they're neoclassical you
said this time it is not different so
who is right so this is now a matter in
in in fact you can really given a
popular media almost every week there
isn't a new article about this topic and
in particular decide new studies
McKinsey has a study governor has a
study Oxford University has a study
osed has a study past water compras is a
study everybody has a study
and every study come up with different
projection for the future so why are we
seeing so many different predictions for
the future well there is a Danish
proverb and he says predictions are hard
especially about the future but I think
the Danish got it got it wrong
predictions are easy especially about
the future everybody can make a
prediction go ahead make a prediction
quite predictions oh this is the hard
part okay now notice all this prediction
usually for 30 years in the future who
is going to check in 30 years where the
Gardner was correct or McKinsey was
quick nobody's going to check it and so
our answer is nobody not what if what's
in the future the future is inherently
unknown okay we can predict the weather
about 24 hours into the future that's
about two maybe few days into the future
instead I want to spend now the rest of
the day a big part of the time talking
about the past and I'm going to use a
case study American manufacturing why
American manufacturing one
first of all United States is a good
test case for this because it's a very
large economy it's about 25% of the
world GDP and it's a very market based
economy more than many of the economies
in Europe for example okay the
government plays smaller role in the
economy here then in many many other
countries a manufacturing is by far the
biggest sector of the economy almost
twice as big of the next sector which is
government and government here is
government in at all level not just a
federal government so manufacturing is
huge just to give you another example of
the size of manufacturing US
manufacturing is about the size of
Germany and Korea and France in Russia
and Brazil and UK combined ok China is
slightly bigger the United States huge
manufacturing is huge this become a
little bit as a surprise because been
hearing ah manufacturing is all gone
right everything went to China in Mexico
but this is all propaganda manufacturing
is huge now here is to me this is a slug
when I saw it it was a shocker so US
manufacturing
look at volume inconstant dollar in this
disco you can see it's been going up for
50 years more than 60 or zero of course
in zigzags there are economic cycles but
it goes up but employment peaked around
1980 and it's been down roughly since
end with some a little recovery off from
the recession here but we have lost
roughly one third of manufacturing jobs
over the past 35 years another way to
look at it which is that a manufacturing
is a fraction of the economy it's very
very stable it's around 12% and it's
been like that for for more than 50
years but we used to have 25% of the of
the of the labor force in manufacturing
and now we are at about 8% so why is it
happening well it's very clear white is
happening it is happening because
manufacturing productivity has increased
over the past 20 years it is roughly
doubled in effect it's surprising we
only lost one third of the labor force
in manufacturing other than half of the
labor force in manufacturing so the
point is if volume is up now what is the
role of China here so because of the
globalized world the mark that in the
manufacturing worldwide is more
competitive and what it meant the u.s.
had to shift from low margin industries
so we don't make sneakers anymore in the
United States this shirt was probably
not made in the United States we move
the manufacturing to high margin high
capital capital intensive industries
okay so when I said that industry is
going up it does not mean that all is
that there is no huge change underneath
an automation globalization are tied
together and automate automation what
globalization is done it has increased
the competitive level and that that
enables automation to become more
profitable
automation' would have happened anyway
because even in this country it's very
competitive so even if we don't have to
compete with China one company will
automate it force the other company to
to me and if you want to see automation
just Google
excuse me search search Tesla Model S
factory floor and you can get very nice
videos of the Tesla factory floor where
they will tell you the only reason the
lights are on so they can take the
picture otherwise could be a dark
factory floor and it reminds me of it
used to be an old joke in GM when they
started putting industrial robots the
joke was the the factory of the future
will have all robots one man and one dog
and the purpose of the doll of the dog
is to make sure that the men does not
touch the machines and all of the of the
men is to feed the dog so now we can ask
okay all this happen all these Mews of
people lost their job what happened this
is a good test guess what happened right
so that the new liberal economist will
tell you all well they should have fun
other jobs there should be a neutrally
balloon
so we now let's go and examine what
really happened and in a nutshell what I
want to show you is the last 40 years
it's been actually very harsh on
working-class and middle-class low
middle-class Americans and this is
something I have to say it's the data
that I share came as a surprise to me
and I've been reflecting on it why is
that I've concluded that we hear a lot
about the 1% but the real dividing
society is not the 1% than 99% is the
20% versus the 80% were the 20%
all of you are part of the 20% because
you are educated professionals and
that's roughly people with undergraduate
and postgraduate education that's about
20% of the population and for these
people if you think about how you spend
your life I would bet the vast majority
of your friends belong to the top 20%
and if you have a spouse most likely
your spouse come from the same group so
this group creates its own bubble we all
live inside this bubble and everything
is filtered through that bubble and we
see very little what's happening outside
that bubble we have little idea what's
happening in
decaying towns in the south or in in the
Midwest and and the bottom line is that
I want to share another automation poses
a very very serious talent to developed
economies we can discuss a developing
economist if you want at the very end
and I think as a society we must develop
policy to address this challenge so
let's see what happened to to the
economy over the last 40 years so this
is data that was put together by Eric
bina from Andrew McAfee at MIT and they
have looked at phone numbers that are
very important here one is productivity
because the economy goes either because
there are more people or people become
more productive and so productivity
growth is the engine of economic growth
and indeed you see here that from the
early 50s for the next 30 years
productivity goes and with productivity
GDP grows the economy goes jobs are
generated and income goes so this is
kind of the Goldilocks the Goldilocks
period and you look at all these numbers
and you think ok that's so nicely well
aligned did you think there must be some
economic law that productivity goes
drive everything everything goes up
accepted what happened starting from the
roughly to her mid 1980 we see a
divergence we see a decoupling and he
stood the day the quad activity
continued to growth and the GDP grows
but were not creating enough jobs and
income has stagnated and here is an
example of income stagnation this is a
thing a nice way to look at income
stagnation this is real median yearly
income of white men with no college
degree and you can see that it's
actually has gone down between 75 and
2015 has gone down and this is I have to
set a few slides over to me when I saw
them I gasped because to realize that
here in the United States for a very
large sector of the economy people think
have gone be now gone wrong now for 40
50 years kind of shocking and think
about what we saw in political rally in
2016 we saw angry white men okay now we
used to see this
usually there would be some of in the
Middle East and they usually we say
something like death to America death to
America and now we are kind of finding
these people right here in our meets and
you ask okay what is so what are these
four angry about when this is what they
are angry about okay that's it their
life quality declining for whole
generation and we also have been hearing
a lot about about growing inequality so
this shows you that if you look again
this is between a nineteen eighty in
2013 and you see the bottom ninety
percent decline this is the top one
percent and then you see the people who
really did well out the top one percent
of the top one percent they did really
really well in this economy and in
particular what it means is that part of
the of the American Dream was of life
getting better except what you see here
is that the top one percent used to own
about twelve percent who used to get
about twelve percent of the income it's
gone up to twenty percent the bottom
fifty percent used to get about twenty
twenty percent of the income scan down
it's like some people call in tale of
two countries where one country is doing
better and better and one country is
doing Wars and Wars and and on top of it
we used to think that this is a country
that enables of social mobility that is
to say that every generate the next
generation will do better than the
current generation and what you see here
is that in 1940 if you're 30 years old
the poverty was ninety percent that you
are doing better than your parents when
there were ninety you went thirty years
old now it's 50/50 it's a contours
whether they're going to do better or
wars the new parents when there were a
similar similar age you skip it okay
this is another very significant thing
you hear a lot about how unemployment
now is very very low unemployment that
is reporting the news it's a charade
it's called u3 it's a concept invented
by politician Ozzie to give us good news
because what does it measure how many
people
looking forward jobs are not finding a
job it does not measure how many people
stop looking for a job because they gave
up and this was to me the second gasp
it's the Labour Party's labor vote
participate these are people who are
either working or looking for a job he
said they would call labor force this is
for men between 25 and 54 the reason
it's important to isolate men for two
reason why the picture for women you can
imagine more complicated the first
entered the workforce starting from the
60s now it's also in decline but it's a
more nuanced picture also we're talking
about manufacturing it's mostly men here
you see that it's been going down now
for 50 years and it's even starker when
you look what happened and you include a
Duke education level you see the people
whose bachelor degrees gunned down a
little bit but people with high school
degree or less it's gone down even more
significantly that means that if you
look now at a men with high school
education or less probably about
something like one in four is not
working and this is to me when I hello I
said this is unbelievable this is what
we think of a country in the midst of a
depression when you hear but Greece this
unemployment level of 25 subpar 25
percent not working outside of the labor
force this is this is a I cannot think
of anything listen this isn't to me a
national crisis except if we don't learn
about it I mean though if you dig in
labor economy or say oh yeah we know we
know about this but this is not only
knew that the 25 percent of working
class men are not working working class
men are not working somehow I've did a
lot of hiding and nothing seemed to or
cannot ever apologize for that and the
final thing that I want to show here on
the label is for many many years you saw
that labor and capital are fifth roughly
50/50 percent of the economy and except
again and this was the case for many
years and people thought again it's an
economic law that economy have offered
to be split between capital and labor
but we're seeing again label now
declining for about for about forty
years labor was declining
so what's going on I think the funnel
default the following plot kind of
explain what's going on
this was put by David Otto with an AK on
labor economist at MIT and what he said
let's look and here it's a combination
of many many plots it's of a smooth
curve it look at so-called the skill
spectrum so high-skilled jobs pay well
and lost skill jobs do not pay well and
this looks if you look at the skill
level our jobs being generated or
declining what you see is in the upper
part of the skill spectrum we generate
jobs ok we know that here in a computer
science you know there the demand
exceeds supply for example this is a
high skill job at the very end of the
skill spectrum we're also generating
jobs why is that think of the job of
cleaning table of the busboy cleaning
table at the restaurant so first of all
you want a grand challenge in robotic do
it build a robot that can clean tables
in a restaurant ok we don't have the
technology to do it the level of
dexterity agility and situational
awareness that the robot will will will
will have to exhibit it is way beyond
what we can do but we can tell take
someone who is even not a high school
degree and pay the minimum wage and
they're going to do the job so there is
no reason to automate jobs and it added
part of the spectrum so where do we
automate jobs in the middle of the skill
spectrum why are we automating jobs here
take manufacturing we pay manufacturing
a employee 20 to $30 an hour well it's a
significant investment ok this is three
times four times more than minimum wage
what's the skill level it's medium it's
a fairly routine job you keep doing the
same thing over over and over this is
only thing that we know how to automate
so here this is the sweet spot for
automation what David Otto has shown
auto auto sure what happened over time
and what you see is these switch spots
get border because more a job is the
capability of forwards increased more
and more jobs become can be defined as
routine
it's also move moves to the right moves
upwards okay so this is like the ozone
hole it gets bigger and bigger and one
way you can look at it is by looking at
income of different according to degree
and you can see the people have advanced
degrees this is between 73 and now the
income has risen this is true for so
college if you have just some college if
you didn't finish four-year you have
some college yeah you you you barely
kept up but if you have high school or
less you actually again you have lost
ground these are the jobs that there are
lots of people who can do this job so
they're not paid well at all maybe this
is the problem here let me try tech
meter right let me see what happened
here play clay where is play there we go
I didn't do that okay well okay so we
have forgot to do that here is the the
final gasp gasp slide this is data and
covered by economies to economists at
Princeton they look at mortality and
with all the Borja run healthcare
mortality gets keeps going down because
health care it keeps improving but they
found that this does not does not hold
for white people in the United States it
holds for Hispanics hold for blacks you
can look at board it happens in every
country health care gets better and
better but they found that white in the
United States our our mortality is going
up this between 45 and 54 so this is
middle-aged people
and again if you look at it by education
you find that this is a this is related
to lack of lack of a college education
and if you dig deeper and say okay what
are these people dying from you find the
leading causes arm suicide and drug
overdose we all hear now about the
opioid epidemic and liver diseases and
all of these were they call out this is
of despair these people
are suffering from despair and we can
ask again what's going on I mean we're
talking about right now for example I
believe that opioid epidemic
kill more people than guns can you
imagine what can kill more people gun in
the United States and so and to top it
this is women this is from March of 2016
this is before the primary before there
before even a trump clinch denominator
Republican nomination
The Washington Post look at the
correlation between mortality and voting
for Trump and I found out that that
areas where there was higher mortality
more despair too low voting for Trump
so this economic development have
political serious political consequences
this is what the economy the economists
again put it put counties by different
index of Health metrics and you can see
if as you get healthier becoming this
blower and as you get less healthy it
becomes red oh okay so there is a clear
correlation here between economics and
health and political inclinations and to
me this reminds of a very classic quote
I want to see if anybody recognizes it
all that is solid melts into error all
that is holy is profaned and Men is at
last compelled to face with sober senses
his real condition of life and his
relationship with his kind anybody
recognizes it
yo'ii
I thought it you'll have they like the
Pope if anybody you should have heard
the proper education so so there is
there is a sense of dislocation that
reminds people with the feeling that
happened in the middle of day of the
nineteenth century
we'll then I'll come back in a few
minutes to the Industrial Revolution now
look at all this data and first of all
urine has almost any economic data
people question because everything for
example you look at the I said real
income well real income you have to
factor inflation how do you measure
inflation the different way to measure
inflation every piece of data here is
Conte is somewhat controversial but I
think the general picture will give
something that that even if you need
picot every single a plot here you still
see a general picture emerging but as
everybody tells you correlation does not
imply causation what is the cause of
this in economics it's very hard to
determine causation it's very very
difficult to do it so this is a in 2014
an opinion poll was conducted the Pew
Charitable Foundation conduct opinion
poll amount about 2000 economists and
again it's a poll so it does not tell
you truth we have to take it with a
grain of salt but there was a
significantly it was a plurality for
accepting the automation is a central
reason again it's not the only reason
life is more complicated it's a central
reason for this for the reason for wage
stagnation now I think the picture has
changed and partly because there is a
new study that just came up last year
from economists at MIT and they went
city by city and look at deployments of
an industrial robots versus job losses
and again remember this all correlation
but I think the weight of evidence is
coming more and more that automation
plays a major role in the dislocation of
the working class people now let's talk
about not this argument this time it is
different or not so again the argument
you hear a lot technology destroying job
but it create new jobs
jobs that we cannot even fathom will be
created but let's do a thought
experiment if you're working AI what is
your goal your goal is to look one by
one at human capabilities and try to
test a stream of artificial intelligence
try to be able to build machine will be
just as smart as people let's suppose we
succeed I don't know this will take 20
years or 100 years let's suppose we
succeed somehow because this assumption
means that there will always be
something that people's are better it
and I don't see this why how you can
argue that people will always be better
than machine in fact unless you go into
some metaphysics we are some kind of a
biological machine you know evolution
had millions of years to to perfect us
it may take some time some time for us
to to compete with evolution but I can't
see anybody who come up with an argument
whereby all you people will always be
better than machine in some way I just
don't see that and in fact if economies
should know about anything it's about
the tipping point concepts as a tipping
point okay what is the tipping point
it's a phase transition there was
popular book by Malcolm Gladwell in 2005
demonstrated many many cases where a
quantitative change finally lead to a
huge qualitative change and in fact what
is the biggest qualitative change that
we have experienced in human history
there are few you can certainly cultural
revolution then the Industrial
Revolution so imagine you're an
economist in the Year 1700 and somebody
asks you to predict economic growth for
the rest of the millennium we said well
I have economic data going back since
Moses book that the two tablets and this
data shown me that economic growth is
always maybe point one percent per year
so we get confidence I'm going to
predict for the next 300 years economic
growth will be point one percent per
year well you would be wrong right
because the Industrial Revolution
happened and so are we now in the in on
the cusp of another kind of people
talking about the force in a sort of
illusion I don't know but I don't know
how we can
through that possibility and in fact
this this possibility was was a there
was a very nice parable attributed it
appeared in a paper by vasily lyon TF
who was a Nobel prize-winning economist
and he wrote about as a parable of two
horses having a conversation in maybe in
1910 and one horse isn't is a new
Luddite horse and he tells the other one
other horse was neoclassical have you
heard about the Ford Model T I'm
incredibly worried I think I think this
new technology will destroy jobs for
horses what will we do after deployment
of the automobile and the new classical
Hall says come on technology almost
destroyed job for horses in it create
jobs for horses there will always be new
job for horses jobs we cannot yet fathom
and predict well we know which horse was
right because horse population picked in
1915 and today there's no job for horses
horses are pets this is this is the
reality if your horse we can argue that
maybe it's a better deal for them I
don't know that's a let's say that's a
horse
equine philosophy debate but in terms of
jobs there are no more jobs for horses
so and then people say come on yes not
evolution happen and look everything
worked out we're okay in mind series
really have you learned your history of
course we are okay now we're 200 years
later but they were first of all to
fully adapt when the Industrial
Revolution we had to invent a new thing
a new institution it's called the social
welfare state it took 200 years I mean
the maturity of the social welfare state
happens after World War Two in the 50s
and the 60s many many things in this
country only happened in the legislation
the Great Society administration of
Lyndon Johnson in the 60s so took us 200
years to adapt
okay it was not an easy adapt ation the
Communist revolution was about 100
million people who died in them even in
this country with for good there were
riots with dozens of people not black
people white people being shot by police
we forgot how the how difficult was to
adapt
to national revolution and now we have
learned nothing from it we're going to
repeat we are going to wait for another
200 years of pain and agony before we
learn to adapt to the next phase of
Technology so of course technology
creates open destroyed jobs I mean this
is this is this is obvious but this is
too simplistic will technology create
enough jobs how fast will it create them
what about the skill level so take a tag
driver who lost his job because now the
tracks are being automated and it's
probably going to be the first thing
would be automated would be
long-distance tracking would be the
first thing probably to be automated
before we do it inside in the center of
cities and you tell this truck driver
were very sorry you lost your job but we
have openings people who write software
for autonomous trucks please apply also
where are the jobs being now destroyed
in small cities in the south in the
Midwest
what being created lots of jobs in in in
Seattle ok sell a job sell a house in
Kalamazoo Michigan and move to Seattle
easier said than done people cannot move
location love location location location
was said about real estate and here is
this just came up on a but a month ago
on LinkedIn top emerging jobs look at it
list of jobs they are exciting list of
jobs I don't even know what is what do
you unity virtual reality okay thank you
okay how many of these jobs goes to
people with high school degree so we
have an economy that creates fantastic
jobs at the high end of the skill adder
well you can do can you look at other
cases but I will tell you well then
let's be come back to other type of jobs
okay so this is very recent the oven
it's Yanni down the street from here
that's an article in the in Wired
magazine Walker DiSpirito machine should
try a new job
caregiver well
okay how much do we pay caregiver again
at the high end if you're a physician
assistant you'll be paid well but that
requires several years of training if
you're going to go for a low-level
caregiver pays very little because the
skill level is load a lots of people who
come to the job does not pay well
generally people form move from
manufacturing to services lose 50
percent of their wages this is a big big
loss any of you consider losing 50
percent of your income it's a big loss
but even beyond the money takes this big
guy who used to work on manufacturing
and we said we needed to go and wash old
people and many you can say well it's a
noble job my parents summer needs to
care of my parents the answer is these
people will tell you very often that's
not who I am
and even if they were willing to do that
if they if this big guy would show up in
a nursing home and the cells came here
they probably he'll probably not get the
job they probably hired a woman to do
the job so that cultural biases on all
sides and we can say that irrational we
can complain about them but people are
not widgets people are people they come
with all their biases we cannot ignore
it and we talk about quantity of jobs so
here is to me this is very start go back
to the talk just in 1990 and you find an
industry with a market value of about 65
billion dollar in real dollars and more
than 1 million walk house now go to
Silicon Valley 2016 you find an industry
the big three last company which is
which is a Google and Apple in Facebook
and the market value then was about half
a one and a half trillion dollars less
than two hundred thousand employees so
something about the number of the new
jobs mayor generate but the numbers
don't match the old jobs at work that we
are losing and it's amazing that we went
through election campaign in 2016 and we
heard a lot about trade we held nothing
about automation not from Clinton not
from Clinton and not from Trump I'm not
surprised about time but I'm a bit
surprised about Clinton the only
politician who need to talk about
automation was
Obama who was not running for anything
and he did observe that we are seeing
jobs moving from manufacturing to
services if you are moving and then
people are losing half their income and
it says something which i think is very
important which is kind of get to the
bottom line everything we know about
work in our life is a fairly modern
thing it's not just Industrial
Revolution
it's answer evolution plus the social
welfare state okay
and some people call it the social
compact that we are living by and it
took 200 years to make it happen right
to strike remember we saw the picture of
the of people striking in in Pittsburgh
and we saw the train station burning and
more than 60 people shot by police the
right to unionize abolish child labor
work hour workweek equal pay for women
minority health and safety laws it took
a long time for this to happen and big
fights all over everything because
always there were resistance to every
new improvement in social and labor
legislation there's now a new kid on the
block called universal basic income and
universal basic income the idea is that
we're going to do away with a lot of
welfare program replaced by universal
everybody every citizen gets a monthly
check from the government it's a radical
idea even though it goes back you can
find Thomas Paine writing about it he
said because the land belong to everyone
originally there should be everybody
should get some kind of a land dividend
you find interesting you'll find support
for this ideas from the left but also
from the right people like Milton
Friedman was in favor
charles Murray was in favor and what's
there why do people you can see why the
Socialists would support it why would
people on the right support it for two
main reason one is they hate the nanny
state they hate the bureaucrats making
decision about who should get money they
said we're simple to get everybody money
and and kill huge a part of the
bureaucracy and secondly it will
actually create a more efficient labor
force and the reason is the rebbe labor
market will become more efficient
because right under many people they job
sucks they're not paid well they cannot
afford to look for another job they have
to be there they just don't have the
flexibility look for an
if the heaven a safety network they
would say I hate this job I'm going to
look for another job so so so these are
the arguments that people on the left
and on the right they take this idea one
of the reason that I can be skeptical
about this idea personally is because it
ignored the psychological value of work
it only deal with the socio-economic
value of or ignore this the
psychological value of work where there
is a lot of research at least in today's
culture it plays such a huge role in our
own personal self value and I want to
finish with the court quoting a JSON for
man who was the outgoing chair of
Economic Council of Economic Affairs and
Obama and he says my worry is that it's
not that this time could be different
come to AI but this time could be the
same as what we have that is if you look
at the past 50 years and you just
project forward the same trend you don't
have to change anything you don't have
to say don't be another phase transition
just take it all this trend we have seen
and just extend them for the next 50
years and we're in fairly bad shape so I
think we're facing to me that if you ask
me that kind of two huge policy
challenges and domestic policy
challenges one is climate change and the
other one is what I would call shared
prosperity I mean there's no question
technology will create a menace amount
of wealth how do we do in such a way
that the country is the whole benefit
from it
thank you very much
[Applause]
then so go back to the horses you know
the population of the earth might
decrease over time right and so one
possible solution to this conundrum is
that the human population just shrinks
do you think that's a reasonable
possibility and if so could it happen
fast enough that it would actually avoid
some of the challenges so let me board
in your issue and I said the district
ignore one huge another huge trend in
demographics and the more graphics is
currently one thing we see is ageing of
the population and so only book says all
we need all the orbits we can have to
take care of the older people okay this
is one and the other one is that as
societies get richer generally the
reproductive rate declines so demography
kind of think that we will peak at about
10 billion then we'll start declining I
have to say getting to ten billion they
are talking about somehow the next like
twenty one hundred that to me is just
too far to to really think what happened
I mean I'm just worried about how do we
navigate the next 25 30 years so 2100 is
just a bit too far for me how aging
interact with it this is a huge question
and I have to say I have not seen really
really good answers about it so it's a
it's a very good questions what's going
to be how does how does technology and
automation interact with ageing of the
workforce I have not seen very very good
answers to that I think nobody knows
yeah but it's a good question yes speak
up speak up so I can hear you yeah so
just sort of an observation so you sort
of had on 2020 the idea of the universal
basic income but the thing that you
objected to about it was was that
there's the psychological value of doing
work so so I wonder you know how well
studied is it like suppose we doubled
minimum wage right unemployment is very
low right now undoubtedly it would rise
some but for the people whose
have remaining work they would be
getting substantially more that might be
a way of forcing the people that are
making a lot more money right now to
value the services that those people are
providing more highly and and maybe a
way of spreading things out but maybe
another way other than universal basic
income that still preserves that
aesthetic that you like but so so a lot
of speculation what happened I mean look
part of the issue is what happened when
you know right now our economy is based
on people walking and consuming what
happen if more and more people aren't
walking what will be the engine of
economic growth and there are people who
says well in a world where you know most
of the same produced by robots there
will be suddenly a new human economy
just like that people are not willing
now to pay more for handmade things
somehow there would be a flowers you
know whole human economy that will
create it
i''m answer is nobody knows you know
this is the future you know nobody could
have predicted a hundred years ago how
society will evolve I think we have a
polymer hands now and I don't know that
we can come up with the ultimate answer
but I think on the other hand ignoring I
mean telling telling people don't worry
you know if you tell people you know
some people really look it's hard for
you but your children will do okay maybe
people can take it if you tell people
gonna be hard for you gonna be hard for
your children maybe your grandchildren
will be okay for most people it's not an
acceptable answer right they would like
to see so we need to come up to
something without worried so much what
happened in a very long term answer is
nobody knows would happen in a very long
term there was a question there in the
back so I have a question regarding the
importance of the economy in the first
place
some some of the parties argue that
civilization is not a natural state for
human that actually together is that's
what I want to be so couldn't we have a
different different society or economy
doesn't play such an important role well
there isn't that psychological needs to
be acknowledged where work completely
different system especially when we have
automation for support so Jared Jared
Diamond is famous for what his gun jumps
and steel but he also hold if you google
you'll find an article he wrote
humanity's greatest mistake and he's
argument you money greatest mistake was
starting the Agricultural Revolution he
said we were better off as hunters
gatherer and in a sense you can find the
biblical parable of the expulsion from
the Garden of Eden was in some sense
refer describe what happened right so
they had to go and buy this by the by
the sweat of thy brother shall eat bread
so you know you could be right but for
the last 10,000 years we've been living
as farmers and then as industry and one
thing we know you know we can we may be
able to handle slow changes and we have
adapted human human have adapted in an
incredibly resilient way but we don't
deal well with fast change so if you
have suddenly you said we are going to
go form between now and in 25 years to a
culture of kind of enforced leisure so
some people tell me our leisure is great
I will finally be able to write all the
poetry that I want to hide and the I
always dreamed of taking a watercolour
painting and I want to then want to do
that we actually have data what do
people do and are not working an answer
it depends on their age all the people
watch television
younger people play video games so
somehow we tell to me the future of
humanity is TV and video games I find it
a dystopia hey I don't know about you
yes so most of the charter to shut off
from the US yes these trends around
technology are global do you can you
cite countries that
be doing a better job on the policy
front with so there is a whole other
talk somebody could give on the on the
international aspect of it one thing
that comes very clear when you look at
international data is policy matters
okay
how countries respond to that definitely
makes it makes a difference for example
Germany has Germany is right now still
has 25 percent of the people in
manufacturing but used to be 40 percent
so it's going down but going down more
slowly one word with one way they do
that they're working the working class
people there and better education than
in United States so this is something
we're going to see how how different
countries are responding to that that's
one one issue that we're going to we're
going to face yeah there's this gasp
moment which I first like this we're
developing this technology that is gonna
generate this very painful potentially
next couple of centuries and I'm trying
to think what actionable things we can
do as as responsible scientists to I
don't know the limit what weird for
building for building an atomic bomb so
I'm really trying to identify potential
course of actions for us to help out
we're not economists on this or not so
from the point of view of machine
learning doesn't make sense we are more
thoughtful so you know that they follow
the question is what should we do and
who has the knowledge to do it and the
answer is right now I don't think the
knowledge is coming for us
okay we're pretty much I look around me
we are techies and they what we need to
in fact we tend to typically we end up
being a bit some of dismissive of social
science but some of this answer will
come from social science they need to
work with us partly because they need to
have an understanding where technology
is going what are the trends but the
answer is weather which would have
universal base income or not
this is something that the people from
computer science will come up with the
answer max tegmark for MIT who is now
very concerned about social impact of
Technology said the answer is not less
technology more social wisdom in the
which the way he described it you know
I've been to you know everybody's
looking for some we are again we're
techy we're like one magic bullet will
solve the problem answer is we are not
finding it we find a plethora of things
you know we can look at for example
think tuck poor tax policy so we just
said the tax reform tax reform give
incentive for capital investment is that
what we really need right now maybe we
need investment to for companies to
invest more in the workforce so so right
now we just passed a new lesson about
taxes and this encourages capital
investment and because you can expense
it immediately and less let's say
investment in the workforce so even tax
tax legislation is relevant to this
debate what about education so right now
we are that the education system was
designed if you finish high school you
are ready for the job you're ready for a
job it doesn't work anymore okay we have
to have to rethink our educational
system so the main memory may be may be
moving pieces and I'm I have to say I'm
struggling myself what's what's our
position on this what do we do in this
thing and first of all I would say is
first of all we need to assume
responsibility right let's we are this
technology it's us we've created it it's
not clear that immediately we will say
that we need to do something but first
of all we should say we are part of the
conversation we cannot ignore it yes I'd
like to see a chart that looked at
across our a lot of countries the
proportion of the population out of work
and the likelihood that that country
would have some kind of significant
revolution that would destroy the
society so that's a danger we might not
be able to fix the problem before
something bad happens
so a handle mcafee for MIT his quote is
the people will rise before the machine
will rise and so historically when you
look at countries where the gap
the the inequality grows more and more
and more yeah these are the thing that
leads to very significant political
outcomes I think you look at what's
happening United States now and you says
well I don't know if you call it a
revolution but it's a very significant
outcome of what happened in in 2016 then
what technology is a place for the
government to slow down say the adoption
of automated self-driving cars for
example because you know it would give
society more time to adjust right it's
some level even if we can do it is it
the right thing to allow the states or
cities I mean this opens a very big
question but technology and regulation
so in this country who have basically
said the marketplace will decide which
technology are adopted which kanojo
developed we are the government just
steps aside there are some cases now I
think that it's it's we need to really
seriously question that I would say the
area where I see it is clearly in terms
of cybersecurity you know we when the
automobile was introduced people start
bringing all kinds of measures there was
the National Technology Safety Board
it's from the nineteen twenties people
says well you know technology people are
dying let's do something about it we
cyber with cybersecurity it's just
people are selling well it's like force
of nature nothing we can do to meet this
we are waiting I think what's going to
happen it's going to be some disaster
some real disaster and then people's all
we need to do something until then I
don't see anything happening you can
look at other thing like crypto
currencies does it make sense what are
the risk of cryptocurrency is again
we're just we just unleashed technology
and we let it happen and let's go see
what happens I think we're going to see
I mean look well the situation now that
you have a small number of companies
with a I think the the big tech
companies that will have market equity
of close to three trillion dollars
they'll call you a lot of the small
number of people
not nearly name some of them are paying
very little taxes you kind of put
everything and you can imagine that
Washington would start looking
somewhat askance had taken maybe I mean
I said the same thing I have to say
regulating regulating takers we've so
it's not in their DNA but I cannot you
know it's quite conceivable to me that
somebody will start putting various kind
of legislations about technology I don't
think they would slow down the the
necessarily the flow of energy that's
the development of Technology but there
was amazing piece of news just this week
Apple investors want the company to do
something about the addiction problem
among among children and teenager for in
iPhones but this did not come from the
association of distressed parents is
that Apple investors Wow this is an aha
moment right he some investors are
starting to worry this is bad for
business a Mark Zuckerberg just
announced is going to change Facebook
it's going to be a false for the good
whatever I think we're ready at some
point that there is some the tech has
become such a powerful presence in our
life and completely unregulated the
people are are starting to look at it I
don't know what will happen I think this
is the year where we're going to see
some change from there from the
completely safe fair that will head for
day for the past 50 years
Yuri comments you said poor people in
technology we also change we will be
kind of side works so there's a small
small remark
secondary marketing technology you
cannot stop development technology if
you stop in this country other countries
when boost up for babe American medical
profession work on now stem cells stem
cells other countries with other
countries being topless so unfortunately
I think we come to politics whether they
want it or not and wonder why the
population is more or less reasonable
the political system is completely
unreasonable all your examples most a
few examples were from MIT if I would
give such a talk my examples will come
from Chicago Chicago doesn't generate
jobs right very different school of
economics but I think the economic the
politics in this country is such without
changing the basic structure there's not
much we can do do we want or not somehow
have to change that the political life
so that it becomes more reasonable so
reasonable decisions may be not only
taken but even discuss just without
going into left-right extreme so I don't
disagree with you we have we have right
now a semi dysfunctional political
system I don't have a place many people
are worried about it regard of this is
so many people are worried about it I
don't have a special reason of how we
fix it whenever we could becoming
cyborgs in some sense we are all right I
mean somebody is having a device on
their head and there are some people who
may have device next to their heart you
know at some point maybe this will
happen to the extent that you will
completely change human nature
conceivable to me it's too far out and I
don't really special loop a special lens
into the future tell you let's focus on
what's happened in the next 50 years
after that you know it's kind of science
fiction
yes final question maybe the way you
describe basic income as the kind of
social welfare welfare and charity
policy no no no I did I said it's
actually anti-welfare
it's an anti welfare policy that's what
you think about area that's how are
there people in the component describe
it okay ah but I look at it as a way as
a more economic more fair economic
policy because that the technology
produces inequality because of the way
we do technology transfer right if the
silicon product I like iPhone or laptops
most of the intellectual property behind
it came out of research paid by the
public so the public has been investing
all this time into it and yet it's the
companies who first make the final
product who get all the problem so I
think the basic income would be a way to
create a more fair economic policy as
opposed to charity so I think I you know
I actually agree with everything you say
I think I said that the goal of a people
who couldn't open that one to eliminate
well from program and the idea is that
this is a way to share the wealth in in
an equitable way I said I have one
concern about it and I said it has
proponents on the left on the right an
opponent left on the right one concern I
have is about the the psychological
issue and also you know we used to have
another slogan which was many people my
parents thought this was used to be a
very beautiful slogan okay the slogan
was it's another human recognize it form
each according to his ability to each
according to her needs
okay and people thought wow what a
beautiful slogan what a beautiful idea
you know people were really captivated
by these people who were willing people
so this is such a powerful idea people
are willing to kill for it and in the
experiment took almost a hundred years
before we realized oh my god what a
disastrous idea okay one thing I grew up
in Israel I go up on a kibbutz so what
you do may not know is that you know in
addition to the experiment of socialism
at large there was a parent of socialism
in the small in Israel in the kibbutz
him
in kind of collective settlements and it
had failed in the small as well so this
good beautiful idea intellectual fell in
love with it and human nature proved to
be somewhat resilient against the
forward everybody come up with another
grant such ideas well let's slow down
before we do any grand experiment and
think about the consequences and do it
very very carefully
let Finland run experiment first thank
you very much
[Applause]